- [Narrator] The coronavirus
pandemic has shut down
movie theaters across the country.
With people bound to their homes,
they're streaming more than ever,
and some Hollywood studios
are releasing some films
direct to streaming services
and digital platforms,
shaking up a distribution model
that's been in place for decades.
- The theaters are saying
you're taking advantage
of a crisis here, and the
studios are saying no,
we're meeting consumers where they are,
and a lot of them are stuck at home.
- [Narrator] This trend away from theaters
and toward digital
platforms began years ago,
but experts say the pandemic
could accelerate that shift.
Here's how.
This is the path a film typically follows
as it's distributed in the US.
The top big-five studios
own the legal rights
to movies they produce,
and they distribute them
to several destinations.
Say a film is made and
distributed by Sony.
Normally, the distributing
studio makes deals
with movie theaters like AMC to organize
a wide theatrical release
to over 3,000 screens.
Theaters traditionally
have exclusive rights
to show the film for 75 to 90 days,
a period known as the
theatrical release window.
After that window ends,
the film usually goes
to digital platforms like Apple or Amazon
where it might be available
for digital rental or purchase.
Later, the film is distributed
again at a lower price
and may become available
on DVD or Blu Ray.
Finally, the studio can
sign a deal with Netflix
or another third-party streaming service
or head to cable channels like HBO,
but the coronavirus crisis
is shaking up that model.
Take "Trolls World Tour."
- Yes, Papa Fur?
- [Narrator] On April 10th,
Universal Pictures
digitally released the film
straight to platforms
like AppleTV for 19.99
for a 48-hour digital rental,
bypassing the theatrical opening.
- So theaters have viewed
this as a philosophical
and an existential threat for many years.
They wanna safeguard
that exclusivity window
because they know that it is
still one of the main reasons
people go to the theater,
right, is because they're
showing movies that you
cannot see anywhere else,
and the experimentation
over the last several weeks
with the theaters closed
has really been a source
of friction between
studios and exhibitors.
- [Narrator] The move was
a gamble, but it paid off.
In just three weeks,
"Trolls World Tour" made
nearly $100 million in rentals,
the biggest opening day and weekend
for a digital title ever.
NBC-Universal CEO Jeff Shell
told the "Wall Street Journal"
that the results for "Trolls
World Tour" have exceeded
our expectations and
demonstrated the viability
of PVOD, or premium video on demand.
Theaters were less enthusiastic.
- Whenever Universal
announced that they were
going to do it with other
movies and planning then,
this is key, planning to release movies
with some more fluidity between theaters
and digital platforms even
after theaters re-opened,
it really became open warfare.
- [Narrator] AMC CEO Adam
Aron sent an open letter
to Universal saying
that his theater chain,
the largest in the world,
would refuse to show
any Universal films going forward.
- Universal's decision to
send "Trolls World Tour"
straight to the digital platforms
is going to be remembered
as a turning point in
the relationship between
studios and exhibitors
because it's going to force
some very hard conversations
when the theaters re-open
about why that might not
be a viable alternative
to the exclusive theatrical
distribution model.
- [Narrator] This all happening
at a very bad time for theaters.
Analysts predict there will
be zero box office revenue
in May and a 30% drop for
domestic ticket sales this year.
Some are predicting that
domestic box office earnings
will be around 6.7 billion for the year
down from more than 11 billion for each
of the past five years putting
2020 on track to become
the worst year for the
film industry since 1997.
- A lot of analysts
expect a lot of smaller,
independent theaters to
really struggle through this
and potentially have to close.
It remains to be seen though,
once theaters re-open,
how many screens come back online.
- [Narrator] At the same time,
streaming services are
seeing a rise in viewership.
In April, Netflix reported
15.8 million new subscribers
for the first quarter of the year,
more than double their
forecast from the year before.
- Now the big question
is what is temporary
and what is permanent?
Do consumers say hey look,
why was I going out to
the movie theater at all
when I could get all this right here,
or will they be so desperate to go out
and get outside of the house,
get outside of the living room
that they return to movie theaters
with even more vigor than before?
That's a real, looming question.
- [Narrator] One thing
that's clear is that
"Trolls World Tour" isn't the only movie
being released straight
to streaming right now.
While big-budget tentpole
movies like "Mulan"
will still have a delayed
wide theatrical release,
studios are releasing more
than a dozen smaller movies
direct to digital because of the pandemic.
In April, The Academy
announced that movies released
via streaming would be eligible
for the upcoming Oscars
just this year because of coronavirus.
- A, we don't know how
comfortable people might be
going back to the theater,
and B, we don't know how long
that might take to get them there,
but the other things that's happened
is that because so many of the big movies,
the James Bond movies, the Marvel movies,
have been pushed to next year,
many analysts are saying we
might see some cannibalization
at the box office next year, too.
- [Narrator] Experts
say that the box office
isn't likely to disappear forever.
- One lesson from the
pandemic will be that studios
have been emboldened to experiment
with these distribution strategies
more than they ever were.
(pleasant music)